[Music]
from satellite you can spot them in the
green speckles
Christmas tree farm Christmas tree farm
Christmas tree actually that's Mount
Rushmore
Christmas tree farm let's get to it why
do people have Christmas trees in their
house they aren't in the Christian Bible
and it's such a new tradition that only
one of these four guys had one in the
white house the real story of Christmas
trees involves a lost Grand duchy 1840s
influencers and the unlikely birth of a
custom that you can see from space
foreign
[Music]
stuff has been going on for a while as
imagined in this picture of the Pagan
Roman saturnalia
but by the 1500s and 1600s it had become
a Germanic custom that included this
song about how awesome fur trees are
[Music]
it was big in Northern States including
the duchy where Charlotte of Mecklenburg
strelitz was from Charlotte was a
princess from a relative Backwater but
that didn't stop her from marrying
Britain's King George III the guy who
most Americans know for losing to
America
with her Charlotte brought the German
tradition of hanging a u branch in the
living room and later she also put up a
Christmas tree but Christmas trees were
still mainly a weird German thing it
took a new era to bring the Christmas
tree Main Street
this is a diary entry from Charlotte's
granddaughter Queen Victoria when she
was a 13 year old girl if you can't read
it it says all the presents being placed
round the tree
that entry is from 1832 so the Christmas
tree was a royal custom already thanks
to Charlotte but it was reinforced by
Victoria's 1840 marriage to her German
cousin Prince Albert this kicked off
perfect conditions for the Christmas
tree to go worldwide in America booming
German immigration in the 1840s added a
huge German cultural influence to the
United States at the same time in
England Christmas was becoming a more
significant holiday with Charles
dickens's A Christmas Carol some of the
first Christmas cards and Publishers
like The Illustrated London news
defining mass media with huge
circulations in 1848 they printed this
illustration of Albert and Victoria
around their beautiful Christmas tree
this picture was like a match to the
spread of German Christmas around the
world in America it even showed up in an
influential women's magazine two years
later albeit with some 1840s
photoshopping see how Albert's mustache
and Victoria's Tiara are gone
as early as 1850 in America the
Christmas tree trade was profitable as
Traders brought them from the country
into the city the Christmas tree didn't
have a Flawless ride Teddy Roosevelt for
one didn't like them because they were a
waste of trees his son had to sneak one
into a White House closet
but it became a tradition in houses big
and small it's a custom that Queen
Charlotte from Mecklenburg strelitz
brought with her to England and it goes
on today just outside Charlotte North
Carolina in Mecklenburg County you'll
find Christmas Tree farms that you can
see from space
[Music]